hello and welcome to this video playing
Tom 2165 that is rating I could beam
it's raining here this is close shirt
okay how Miriam maybe mix it up a little
bit playing lots of Petros recently
issues I invested there a lot of time
getting my Petroff bass repertoire on
chasuble on the road and I want you it
is just like you have invested so much
time you want to get it on the board a
little bit and test out what you have
researched this is why I tend to play
the petrov quite a bit it's um I mean
it's objectively a good opening that's
that's clear but it's not like I'm
somebody you recently asked me have you
given up on other openings know what
everything something like that do you
only play the Petroff now awesome and
it's not the case but I think again I
invested a lot of time for researching
the opening and you want to yeah what's
the right expression there you want to
get a bit of a return of investment in
terms of time so play a oh if you've
learned that yet it's a good thing to
test it out and see if you you really
understand what you research okay
yeah I'm just wondering and I have a I
have this night here D 5 a day him I am
that I don't need to sacrifice the porn
okay he's not even trying trying to do
something yeah okay I thought maybe he
can try to gain time on the night
but he doesn't seem to be what he is
after
oh really
it looks weird somehow it just looks odd
okay that's an interesting point
structure my king should sit well on e7
and maybe I can play a little bit here
on the Queen side
no no draw come on
I don't even think the position is that
draws on a stable I am in there there is
always a bit draw in the root ending
edge that's that's that is that's true
but there are there are many things to
try and grill him
okay so I'm stopping his points them
okay so let's check the structure yeah I
got t5 or look f6 I think I just go rook
F six
hmm okay
I wonder what he's doing there with the
King what the what the Indians I have an
idea see for roopd 3d5 mate 45 made next
and it's something that he has to watch
out for
rook to e3 now getting I mean a for
route III whoops he's got I know I mean
I'm not meeting him
I'm aware but still okay no so he is
still okay right he's still okay
[Music]
she's six no it's illegal nothing it's
just so much going on the route d3
business wasn't a big deal I still have
the slightly better pawn structure but
it's it shouldn't be all that relevant
mean because of b2 b2 is a bit weaker if
you imagine I get rook b8 and I mean it
probably has to go back and then yeah
maybe maybe I got a little something now
he okay
now I can try to come come from behind
with the rook
no sorry this isn't know that it's not a
draw
I just just a normal position I'm not
making a draw here and I'm not losing on
time this is increment Ches
okay so he gives me c3 right I'm taking
it
okay b7 I have to go to g7
or just see true
[Music]
yeah it's also possible
Wow he got really terrible weather him
some support the point from behind
so how do we do this skin G for know
this one
oh I didn't didn't see this mofo
it isn't best just a come on a you want
to what kind of a [ __ ] is that like
every five moves he offers to draw or
something it's it's crazy now the single
one of those positions was draw like
clean draw and just this is just
annoying
I'm sorry for a coma appointed [ __ ] but
I mean what what what is that like
offering offers four times the draw or
something no come on not going to give
you a rematch that is just silly why
should I make it wrong I wasn't a single
reason every one of those positions was
easily playable and in some cases just
better for black okay so let's have a
look it's getting really dark there
right so ii 5 yeah 95 you can play this
move it's quite interesting like this
should give me a pretty good play it's
something that I had on the board
the once and it came that was this motif
maybe the exact exactly the same
position he keeps could play some 90
form it's not the only possible I was
thinking it's more testing to not
immediately try it with 92 okay it's
it's possible okay yeah that was I
thought an interesting Quan structure
there for an ending my King defends the
Jeep on and they have some some ideas to
play so yeah this I felt was already a
little bit easier for black young my
King is doing a little bit more and I
have the slightly more compact structure
okay let's see six
you know I was I was heading
I was hoping a little bit - I was hoping
for more that's what I was trying to say
with this route d3 but it doesn't really
doesn't really do all that much each
five is a cool move here yeah this is
the idea I guess that's really neat it's
not easy to figure out and you can take
here and go away five but the engine
believes that I'm better here probably
the check and then look a six it's so
difficult
okay I'd simply took and yeah then this
ending is not nothing in particular but
it is a little bit simpler for me to
play for Shuang the engine gives me 0.7
yeah ultimately went went for b4 which
which blunders the pawn I didn't play it
right yeah technically that was very
sure d4 already wins them okay yeah
you cannot he cannot stop the pawn yeah
that's very simple okay I just took it
now that was probably not the greatest
technical play ever I can just play
deform yeah it's okay if the two points
will do the job I can just do this it's
very simple that is not great I mean of
course blacks better but you're not
certain that you win and very likely you
don't but he makes and made some why he
went for a rather passive defense that
probably should not hold
I had no time so I needed to gain a bit
of gain a bit of time there he H five is
the thing you have to get rid of upon
until you're probably lost I wouldn't be
surprised if that's the case the engine
is still giving a draw
it was definitely definitely lost after
route g6 that is definitely losing the
engine wants to play the check it's the
only way to draw King III King f1 yeah
yeah that's it oh no that's a draw
something like this you're on the short
side it's a it's a fairly easy draw and
that is just allowing me to to promote
the pawn yeah I don't know it I think
it's quite silly to often form four
times or something I mean in blitz you
know why dude why offer a draw and in
more in many of those positions
it wasn't even equal then okay guys
thanks for watching